welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and marvel's eternals reveals the
godlike beings hidden on earth since the
beginning
spending all their time playing with
their playstation vr headsets while
doing shots from the holy grail
not a bad way to burn a millennium but
these relatively lesser-known marvel
characters are actually
critical missing links to the broader
marvel ancestry a lineage that connects
humankind to
thanos the celestials the cree the
skrull and soon the mutants
there's a lot to explain and as marvel
loves to break our hearts with the voice
of stan lee but the one thing that will
never change
we're all part of one big family
i'm gonna break it all down as a marvel
cosmic
ancestral family tree so let's start
with this new group the eternals we're
meeting 10 of them icarus ajak fina
fastos
gilgamesh cersei kingo makari sprite and
drink they never age they possess
various super abilities but the eternals
were actually one of three groups
created on earth by the celestials the
giant armored space gods of marvel lore
the celestials arrived to earth in
ancient times they trapped a primordial
ape and from it
they spawned the deviants the humans and
the eternals earth's deviants were
monstrous war mongers so the eternals
were created as protectors who
perpetually resisted the deviants
meanwhile humans were formed as
inheritors of earth keen to destroy but
capable of achieving peace
all about that potential now within the
eternals vena's bloodline goes back a
bit being his grandfather was kronos
a first generation eternal who suffered
an insane lab accident to become the
living embodiment of time itself kronos
had two sons
zurus that's thena's father a zeus-like
figure and alars aka
mentor who left earth for saturn's moon
of titan
where he and sui-san bore two children
arrows aka star fox
and thanos so thanos is an eternal but
he possesses a deviant gene resulting in
a scarred purple skin
something suicide hates so much she
tries to kill him at birth but this
deviant g and also makes him more
powerful than a typical eternal now the
marvel cinematic universe has kept this
mostly intact red skull identified
thanos as
but mcu thanos's planet titan is not the
moon of saturn but rather its own planet
outside of our solar system
and yeah this makes thanos and then
first cousins i know the resemblance is
uncanny but back on earth humanity
obviously bred like rabbits but the
celestials had granted humanity the
capacity to develop their own
superpowers
which manifested as the mutant gene
causing mutant kind to branch
off and we saw this with insaboner the
ancient egyptian mutant who became
apocalypse and over time all the other
mutants like james allen logan wolverine
charles xavier and the x-men
magneto all those great guys but part of
mutant history is actually further
genetic tinkering which led to figures
like nathaniel essex mr sinister
and the high evolutionary herbert
wyndham who many believe
created rocket raccoon and a guy who had
a lab on wundergore mountain where the
maximoff twins spent their early years
depending on whether or not marvel
studios actually pulls that trigger and
makes them mutants
also another early mutant was namor
prince of atlantis an undersea kingdom
formed after an ancient war with the
deviants
who sunk their own undersea kingdom of
lemuria something that we might be
seeing with that volcanic eruption in
the eternals trailer now in the past
athena actually fell
in love with a deviant named crow but
they were forced to break up
similarly cersei previously betrothed to
icarus
has a forbidden love affair now with the
human dane whitman which seems like it's
gonna be the central plot of eternals
but let's climb back
up to the celestials there are over a
dozen known celestials in the marvel
comics but the ones we know will appear
in eternals from the concept art and the
toy leaks
include arishum the judge nazar the
calculator
hargen the measurer and jemiah the
analyzer each celestial plays a
different role in assessing a planet's
worth and deciding if it should be
destroyed
similar to how galactus is a kind of
cosmic custodian
the celestials created all these things
they leave them on their own they check
back in to see if they're doing okay
and i think we can assume that divine
assessment is
the end of the world battle that the
eternals film is setting up but before
we continue
special thanks to extra for sponsoring
this video exter is the world's largest
smart wallet brand they design the
smartest wallets in the world which you
can track with their solar powered
tracker worldwide so if you ever have
trouble finding your wallet your tracker
is here to help you find it instantly
it's voice activated and solar powered
two hours of sunshine gives it a
three-month charge
just download the chipolo app on your
phone and you can ring your wallet from
your phone or your phone from your
wallet it works with google home alexa
and siri so check it out i'm just going
to slip this in my wallet uh-oh lost it
so i bring up the chipotle app and i hit
ring to find or i'll do it voice
command-wise
hey uh siri where's my wallet
oh i threw it over there and forgot
found it and then extra slim
profile wallets are awesome they're made
of premium leather they have rfid
protection and you use this little
button on the side to
instantly fan out your cards like so no
more overstuffed wallets no more giant
lumps in your back pocket so check out
the wallets with the link below and earn
an additional discount with our code
extra.com
new rockstars they're currently running
a father's day promotion with
up to 25 off and you can use our
discount code of
rockstars and you'll get an extra five
percent off on top of that that's code
rockstars to maximize your savings at
xter.com
new rockstars now guardians of the
galaxy showed us another celestial issan
the searcher
we also know that ego is another
celestial he mated with the human
meredith quill to produce peter quill
making him half celestial and then of
course
nowhere the severed head of a past
celestial in the comics nowhere was
killed by the symbiote deity null
but since the symbiotes seem like sony
properties some believe that the mcu
version of these
events could be that nowhere died in the
past war against the celestial's
creators
so yeah we gotta go up a rung higher and
to do that we got a look at the new
origin described in the
ultimates volume two number six in 2017
actually published right
as marvel studios was beginning
seriously developing this eternals film
in this updated mythology in the
beginning there was the first
firmament the very first living
embodiment of the original universe
before
eternity even and out of loneliness the
first firmament created beings he called
the aspirants
who then created beneath them
multicolored rebels that we know as a
celestials and then everybody went to
war
from this eternity was formed maybe an
aspirant killed nowhere
and then within eternity our celestials
were left to
fiddle with their flesh puppets on earth
and on other planets
the cree homeworld of holla was touched
by celestial influence
creating a race of cree eternals like
ardcon
and creed deviants now the cree lifelong
enemies the skrulls were actually the
deviant strain from their home world
that won
out the cree race plateaued nearly 60
000 years before earth humanity matured
and the creed genome stabilized out of
fear of mutation like what they saw the
scroll as
so essentially the cree stopped evolving
and that led the creed to begin
conducting their own celestial style
experiments
one of which resulted in the inhumans
back on earth they live on a secret base
on the moon
which some of their eyes could be where
old steve rogers is hanging out after
all those falcon winter soldier clues
now finally the asgardian's connection
to the celestials is less clear
since the thor comics predated the
eternals comics but in the later years
earth x comics the asgardians are
described as aliens that were
manipulated by the celestials who put
them in the third tier of the celestial
mutation cycle that makes the asgardian
appearance powers and identities defined
by the belief of
others in this case the norse people
whom odin saved projecting their norse
mythology
onto their asgardian saviors so there
you go
marvel's cosmic ancestral family tree
and really i should say just a piece of
it because we got figures like galactus
watchers elders that either predate the
celestials in the big bang or just
transcend the universe in various
bonkers ways but the eternals and the
celestials are the keys to all of it so
for any skeptics who are still looking
for reasons to watch eternals
wake up and smell the mythological sex
to support this channel please check out
one of our many great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com you can follow me
on instagram and twitter eaboss follow
new rockstars
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis and breakdowns of everything
marvel thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you